[Music]
I really really really love to continue
playing Ellison and the pilot was so fun
for many reasons but also I really loved
seeing Allison's character grow and part
of it is also that you can't make me a
teenager anymore it can't do it that's
kind of fun terrible thing to say but I
feel like we where we play teenagers so
much that it was really nice to kind of
be this adult figure right it was it was
like flipping the tables it was such an
interesting perspective and way of
exploring Allison's adult side and and
how she's dealt with this space that you
haven't seen yet and there's so much
room for her to grow and for the fans
just to explore which I love and you
meet these wonderful well-rounded
characters and I think the fans will
definitely look at the chance all in
love with these new people and their
struggles and their lifestyle and I
think you can relate to it in the pilot
do we see Allison as a mom with those
twins I don't think I can reveal that
that the twins okay very awesome and
they're okay but I think Marlene won't
get me get mad and I also don't get
fired okay start that's the good news
that that is true I think I think that
is the one thing that people would
strike about so I'm kind of I'm kind of
safe I'm curious about this just
personally Allison and Mona were not the
best of friends and Mona goes to Paris
at the end of PLL so how does that come
to fruition I guess when I read the
draft that we were gonna film I I
cracked up in so many spots because of
the way that they tightened their two
characters they kind of become allies in
a way and it's this very interesting
kind of dynamic because Allison's
obviously not sure if she can trust
Monash when you ever trust no no I know
but the way that she ends up being in
this new town is is very mysterious but
also hilarious the way she kind of rides
over you ask questions and I think the
fans will appreciate that
mystery there there's enough told that
you know okay we'll find out but a
hilarious way of Mona putting it across
yeah yeah
nobody good any cameos from anyone in
the pilot I should not say that okay but
that's not a no sana no but it's not yes
okay I like that what was your favorite
part about the pilot
I think obviously being with Janelle and
having this familiarity with that yeah
but also just a new experience we shot
in Portland which was great was my first
time to Portland and it felt new and
fresh but at the same time it was that
family vibe I think we all gelled
immediately and and felt really good
about it the crew that we worked with
they filmed grim and Portlandia together
and so they feel really established and
we connected just just so well it felt
like we've been doing five seasons
already yeah so I think knowing that it
it felt so good and so strong was kind
of the best part because I was like yeah
I could definitely do this for you know
a long time is it darker than Pretty
Little Liars I think it's definitely
darker than how our first season of PLL
was I feel like it picks up from PLL
kind of seamlessly there's a two-year
gap around yeah and it just it is it
will be darker that way
are you still teaching yes I feel very
official Wow lasers and like it's very
high-tech and Deegan Heights which I
really appreciate
yeah I'm so much more about this but
Marlene did say that not all the
perfectionist are female
yeah that's right I also really love ya
house actually yeah I can see that yeah
who was in our movie ended up being in
our pilot and I kind of freaked out you
know with that mm-hmm Hugh who played my
husband on PLL uh-huh is really good
friends with Chris and obviously I know
Chris and I also know Chris his wife and
he's like hey he's coming out for this
role what um
I emailed our casting director Gail and
I was like you have to hire him
immediately and he was the last
character we
cast Wow we just had a ball so yeah have
you seen so fabulous the pilot no it's
not fair I feel like well like the cast
is usually the last people to see it
yeah yeah obviously before I fancy it
but what are you gonna do if it does get
picked up like how are you gonna sell it
we're gonna have a dance party yeah for
sure
no I'll probably be on a plane look to
go promote it which would be this would
be amazing so oh my gosh I'm over the
pass
are you not gonna be able to have a
honeymoon oh no I will have it's in my
contract I have three daughters in my
contract
yes to be able to yeah to do that